It was,
we got very interested in dreams and started to understand the relationship
between dreams and myths because he would see in his client's dreams,
echoes of stories that he knew because he was deeply read in mythology and,
and then he started to believe that the dream was the birthplace of the myth and
that there was a continual interaction between the two processes,
the dream and the story and storytelling and well,
you know,
you tend to tell your dreams as stories when you remember them.
And some people remember dreams all the time,
like two or three at night.
I've had clients like that and they often have archetipal dreams that have very
clear mythological structures.
I think that's more the case with people who are creative,
by the way,
especially if they're a bit unstable at,
at the time,
because the dream tends to occupy the space of uncertainty and to concentrate on
fleshing out the unknown reality before you get a real grip on it.
So it's like the dream is the birthplace of thinking.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And so because it's the birthplace of thinking,
it's not that clear.
It's doing its best to formulate something that was Young's notion as opposed to
Freud who believed that there were sensors,
internal sensors that were hiding the dreams.
True message.
That's not what you and believed.
He believed the dream was doing its best to excel,
to express a reality that was still outside of fully articulated conscious
comprehension.
It was cause you think,
look a thought appears in your head,
right?
That's obvious pit bang.
It's it.
It's nothing you ever ask about.
But what the hell does that mean?
A thought appears in your head.
What kind of ridiculous explanation is that?
You know,
it just doesn't help with anything.
Where does it come from?
Well nowhere.
It just appears in my head.
Okay,
well that's not a very sophisticated explanation as it turns out.
You know?
And so you might think that those thoughts,
thoughts that you think,
well where do they come from?
Well they're often someone else's thoughts,
right?
Someone Long Dad,
that might be part of it.
Just like the words you use to think our utterances of people who've been long
dead.
And so you're informed by the spirit of your ancestors.
That's one way of looking at it.
And your motivation,
speak to your motion,
speak to in your body,
speaks to you,
and it all does all that,
at least in part through the dream.
And the dream is the birthplace of the fully articulated idea.